give me that Kardashian tea and I are
you talking about gossip I am going to
try a two-week tea detox I don't really
know what the [ __ ] that means but I'm
here I've seen this trend all over my
Instagram Kim Kardashian's endorsed it
all these like celebrity models have
endorsed it so it's like their bodies
look great but is it the tea or is it
the personal chefs and their trainers
that they all have money to afford fit
tea and me just eating garbage and
living my garbage lifestyle probably
isn't gonna help that much maybe it'll
be a lifestyle change maybe I'll start
hiking more and other things but people
do we'll see if it actually holds up to
its label very light supports metabolism
boost energy and reduces bloating it's
not approved by the FDA awesome let's
get a whiff of this bad boy
oh do not put that close to your nose
that is strong but it smells really good
Wow
look at that this [ __ ] is like straight
out of Beverly Hills I feel like I'm
gonna take a sip and immediately feel my
balance moving here we go this is for
you Kim you can definitely taste the
lemon it's got a lot of zest lemon and
it just you know has a very strong aroma
tea is just you know better than having
coffee with cream and sugar every
morning hopefully I'll have a Kardashian
body by the end of this
it's tea time drinking my first cup of
tea and honestly I'm pretty into it
it's exactly like coffee it's waking me
up it's maybe the placebo effect I would
drink it consistently in the morning I
just felt like it gave me a kick start
to my morning I was like super energized
so I just drink the tea and surprisingly
I feel really awake right now and my
heart's beating really fast and I don't
know if it's supposed to do that I have
to say I didn't do it in the morning and
I just did it kind of like in the
afternoon and I have like an extra spunk
in my staff I've noticed that I'm really
tired and just very low-energy and the
thing was advertised as an energy
booster so this is venti like only tea
can't just make you thin like are you
dieting and exercising oh no I literally
like throughout the day would have to
remind myself make sure you eat your
dinner on the way home it's like why am
I not hungry I think the thing that
confuses me most is by celebrity
pictures
like this and they don't even drink it
probably it's my second week on the tee
and it's already suppress my appetite
I'm not that hungry and it's noon it
tastes very potent it's I love the aroma
of the tea but it's just definitely not
something that I want to drink every day
I really miss coffee I drink tea for two
weeks and literally nothing happened I
am Nick Guillory and I do not endorse
this product you see this I'm literally
the same size I think that regular green
tea will suffice just as well as fit tea
like I don't really see a difference I
mean I've been pooping two to three
times a day I don't know if it's related
to this I did feel like I was going to
the bathroom or which like isn't ideal
to drink and then go to work because
you're just like with all your
co-workers and your like stomachs
rumbling overall it's not that special
it's not like a magic to your
[Music]
you